interim Scott selected three sets of  Scottish bagpipes for experimentation  with the Clockworks in an attempt to  make a new instrument the first set was  placed on the setting one to one and the  output produced was the same scent  colored a different shade of tartan the  second set was placed on the setting  fine and the output produced was one set  of bagpipes that anomalously filled with  air despite having no blow stick it also  lacked a brass drone the final set was  placed on the setting very fine the  machine produced a set of bagpipes that  when held forced the user to play Flower  of Scotland repeatedly until either the  bagpipes were taken from them by force  or they collapsed from exhaustion